the late John a Bonner was an
outstanding sound engineer he was the
director of special projects at Warner
Hollywood studios an Academy governor as
well as a longtime chairman of both the
SciTech and the sound committees he
represent the John a Bonner medal of
commendation is the Academy's first
Science and Technology Council
Council fellow in Gordon o Sawyer Award
recipient please welcome mr. Don Rogers
when I told my wife I was going to be a
presenter tonight her eyes got real big
and she said mm-hmm honey there's a
reason we're behind the camera not in
front of it
the truth is words will be hard for me
tonight
John Bonner was my friend and associate
for over 40 years this award was named
an honor of him because the X the level
of excellence and devotion that John
brought to the Academy was deserving of
this recognition it's now given to
others an appreciation for outstanding
service and dedication and upholding the
high standards of the Academy over 30
years John gave thousands of hours to
the Academy he set standards that are
still recognized his state of the art
I'd like you to welcome John's wife
Shirley Bonner and the previous
recipients of the John Barr award would
you please all stand
I'm deeply honored to present the John a
Bonner
medal commendation to my dear friend and
associate tad I'm Charles tad Marburg
is particularly meaningful to have you
present this award it reminds me of the
tremendous its support encouragement
you've given me over the years and thank
you Doug Stewart for that great and
thoughtful video pronunciation of my
daughter's name aside we'll talk about
that later I was kind of hoping that
some of my visual effects friends could
have done a little something to those
picture of the old me I guess the Bonner
doesn't include Photoshop I'd like to
thank Cheryl Boone Isaacs our
exceptional and fearless leader the
Board of Governors Richard Edlund Dave
English scientific and technical Maine
Committee this great award and to all my
colleagues who kept us a secret one of
the most interesting aspects of our
industry is the coexistence of science
and art to the world at large they may
appear to be too disparate disciplines
however I don't think they are unrelated
at all without the science we would not
have the art and without the art we
wouldn't have the science at least not
in motion pictures I've come to realize
this conundrum has been one of the
fascinations of my professional life
because it's brought me into contact
with great artists great scientists who
provided the technologies expressed
their work the Academy of Motion Picture
Arts and Sciences represents both much
like many of you in this room embody
both as well I think this is why the
Academy has always been like a magnet
for me and I've wanted to do anything I
could to support and be a part of it
the bonnet is an honorary award for
service to the Academy named after John
Bonner who set such a high standard
exemplifying service and volunteerism
within the Academy it's a tremendous
honor to receive this award and when it
comes a responsibility to uphold the
standards which it represents I just
like volunteering and it's all the
better when it relates to something I'm
passionate about I love movies I love
working in the in the business how many
times do we get to say that I never
sought any reward for volunteering my
services just felt good to do it and it
sure feels good to be recognized by the
Academy it also feels great to
contribute to this organization as it
grows and changes as well as to be able
to mentor the next generation of
filmmakers keep closing I'd like to
thank my family we're all here tonight
my son Lauren my daughter Jenna and of
course the love of my life my wife Mila
who gave me a Hall Pass to spend the
time serving the Academy and continues
to do so as I plan to keep giving my
time because it means a lot to me on so
many levels
thank you